the first known disaster in the final
destination franchise takes place in
victorian england in 1889
when rising gas from some underground
construction causes the explosion of a
house at number four mornington crescent
thanks to the vision of a young girl in
juliet collins there are seven survivors
but one by one and death would reclaim
them
newsman matthew upton was impaled by a
chemical filled pipe historians hector
barnes jane stanley and their protege
andrew are poisoned by snake bites
surgeon stuart tubbs inhales a poisonous
gas and serial killer bill sangster is
caught in the gears of a drawbridge
these events are the first known example
of what i'll be calling the flight 180
phenomenon where accident survivors are
picked off one by one after avoiding
death this usually happens when a
clairvoyant a character with an ability
to foresee future events has a vision of
his or her own death and saves their own
life and possibly the lives of others
forcing death to change its ways and
reclaim its rightful victims there is a
lot of mystery surrounding death is
death just a force of nature
no different than time or gravity or is
it an entity a grim reaper with its own
thoughts
plans and vulnerabilities in this video
i'll be analyzing every death in the
series
including the ones that occur off screen
in the novels and in the comics this
video is sponsored by hunterkiller
welcome to horror history before i
continue on with the history of death
which is essentially the final
destination timeline here are a couple
of disclaimers for this video i'll be
using the sequel timeline in the first
final destination movie we see that
flight 180 crashed on may 13th 1999.
however in the sequels that date has
been moved to may 13
2000 and i've theorized that this has
something to do with this line in the
first movie where alex looks up at the
stars and wonders if there could be a
world where the flight 180 passengers
are still safe
second disclaimer there is at least one
premonition incident that we don't know
the details
of which occurs before the other
accidents
it's just that i've seen this before a
lucky few survive a disaster
and then one by one
death comes for the wall i've theorized
that this could be william bloodwort's
own near-death experience but as of
right now we don't know for sure
third disclaimer outside of the movies
there are final destination novels and
comics while they don't seem to directly
contradict the canon of the movies from
what i can tell they
are out of print not having access to
them it's hard to say when they all take
place chronologically so i'll start with
the ones that i can't place in the
timeline with all of that being said
let's get into it
in final destination dead reckoning punk
rock singer jess golden saves some lives
with her vision of a collapsing
nightclub the bouncer in sebastian is
later killed by his exploding motorcycle
a student named amber is run over by an
out of control car a jock named charlie
falls down an elevator
shaft a cop named marina is poisoned by
a black widow a waitress named macy is
struck by a metal pain an alcoholic
named ben falls into a manhole and a
drug dealer named eric is hit in the
head into the surfboard
the book also describes what is perhaps
the only visual depiction of death's
true form
in jess's dreams she sees a horrific
monstrosity of shifting bones and
corpses that supposedly represent death
several months later jess and her friend
jaime are nowhere to be found so it's
unknown if they found a way to beat
death
in final destination and destination
zero and journalist patty fuller learns
that she had a great grandmother who
once cheated death by being revived
after she drowned in a river patty had
her own vision and foresaw the bombing
of the south hill metro line in los
angeles she managed to get some people
off the train before it happened the
survivors include hal who later drowned
in a flash flood
zack a construction man who was cut in
half by a glass pane and susan a
mechanic who was burned to death
then there was al who was beheaded by a
flying hubcap while receiving what i
will refer to as a mobile pipe cleaning
service by a professional
named candy and will he was impaled by
cds and dvds from a now defunct
electronics store i'm guessing that is
not
just what he needed patty eventually
dies of an intentional overdose so that
she can be revived and theoretically go
on living just as her great-grandmother
once did
many years ago in final destination end
of the line recent high school grad
danny king has a vision about a train
crash at 32nd street in new york city
this time the survivors include renoka
who is crushed by a bathtub that falls
from the floor above peter who was
impaled by the horns of a gazelle
jack who falls onto a wine corkscrew
that impilled him in the eye mary beth
who was butchered by a chainsaw dropped
by a construction worker
and bodily and james who are both part
of a wild series of events culminating
in them being thrown from the top of a
moving truck into his store display of
umbrellas that impale them
the last two remaining are dany and his
sister louise what happens to them is
very interesting and potentially
exhibits another rarely seen ability of
death
luis tries to do what patty fuller did
so she can technically die by injection
but be revived
only new life can defeat death but when
luis comes back she accidentally cuts
the brakes while adjusting her brother's
motorbike and in his final moments dany
realizes that luis was only revived in
order to play a part in his death
this is significant because it means
that death has the ability to use the
victim's survival tactics against them
however
this alone is not enough to prove that
death is a conscious entity rather than
a natural phenomenon what happens to
luis afterwards is not known but the
next novel final destination dead man's
hand would introduce a new facet that
would change our perception about death
in the final destination franchise
the holiday gift grind is upon us i
seriously don't know what to get anyone
this year clothes know where to wear
them video games yeah like anyone wants
to spend more time watching screens
after a long day of zoom calls and also
the priority for screens should be
watching cz's world videos because i'm
here to tell you about the perfect gift
for you
or that horror fan in your life it's the
blair witch game from hunt to killer
you've probably watched a horror movie
and thoughts why would you get into a
car with a bunch of other people that
the grim reaper wants to kill
well this is your chance to see how
you'd fare in the middle of a blur witch
story
over the course of a season you'll be in
charge of solving the mystery of black
hills
forest you'll be sent six boxes
containing realistic evidence maps
police reports and more to provide a
horrifying and immersive experience this
is one of their best stories yet because
it feels like you're stepping into a
world of blur witch lore
right now horror history viewers can go
to huntykiller.com
cz's world and use code cz's world for
20
off your first box again make sure to
use code cz's world for a 20
discount and to show your support for
the show can you survive the curse of
the blair witch
the next novel is final destination dead
man's hat ali goodwin gets married to
her ex-boyfriend one drunk night in
vegas and saves five lives when she
foresees the glass elevator collapse in
a hotel called merlin's tower
sure enough death comes for all of the
escapees but unlike the other disasters
i've mentioned so far they do not die
in the same order that they died in
during the premonition and this is
because of another rule of death if
someone
intervenes with death's plans and saves
a life that person will be skipped but
death will come back around for them
after completing its list
because of this it starts with an exotic
dancer named shauna who is rammed into a
slot machine by a special prize car that
rolled off of its display platform guess
it wasn't her lucky day at the slots her
boyfriend a man named warren ackerman
dies shortly thereafter when a power
line falls into the puddle than standing
it
then a gambling addict named arlen is
killed during
a pipe cleaning disaster involving a
severed pipe that seems to have
preferred methods of taking people out
and i guess in the books it really likes
to
interrupt the clarinet practice ali's
newlywed husband thomas is hit by a
speeding truck another commonly used
tactic of the reaper but ally's death is
much less in line with the usual methods
found in the world of final destination
after her initial premonition she was
sprayed with blood by one of the victims
that she was unable to save from the
elevator and once she is the last
remaining survivor she finds out that
she contracted hiv from that blood we
don't see her death but it's heavily
implied that she does not survive
this is perhaps the only subtle death
among all of those who cheated death's
design
i think william bloodworth's explanation
is the best answer as to why so many of
them pass on in such a gruesome manner
the risk of cheating the plan
of disrespecting the design could incite
a fury that could
terrorize even the grandfather and you
don't
even want to [ __ ] with that i think the
basic implication is that if you mess up
death's original plan for you it's going
to be much scarier when your fate
finally does catch up with you final
destination sacrifice is an interesting
departure from the standard formula
because the protagonist has many
prophetic visions the first is a bus
accident but he's unable to convince
anyone else to get off the bus and he is
the only survivor
next he sees a factory explosion and
this time he's able to save himself and
four co-workers but soon finds out that
he has only delayed each of their
appointments with death
after a latter accident a bathtub
electrocution a lawnmower malfunction
and a railroad splattering he once again
finds himself
the only survivor next he envisions
himself and his family
dying in a gas explosion at this point
he's overwhelmed with grief and decides
to hang himself thinking that if death
got what he wanted with him
the people in his life would maybe no
longer be in danger there are two ways
to look at this story
it could be that death is not perfect
and the first three attempts were
unsuccessful or it could be that the
suicide was in the cards for him all
along there were a few other disasters
referenced in news articles but it's not
clear
when they take place they include a
building collapse that kills 14
a bus crash that takes 32 an electrical
fire that destroys an office
a capsized boat resulting in the loss of
four lives a ferris wheel that sends
nine more souls to the afterlife an
accident in the gulf that kills 18 and a
hardware store accidents that claims two
which we only know to take place
sometime after april of 2003.
that's it for the ambiguously placed
entries if you know when some of these
take place
please do drop me a comment from here on
out the order of events are more clearly
spelled out which takes us to the end of
april 2000.
the office employees of a new york
branch of presage paper set out on a
business retreat
but as their bus crosses the north bay
bridge the structure begins to collapse
a part-time salesman named sam lawton
has a premonition causing him to take
his ex-girlfriend molly harper and flee
the bus
six others give chase and as a result
they are the only survivors at the
funeral for the deceased employees they
encounter william bloodworth who warns
them that death does not like to be
cheated and over the next couple days
each of them would find out exactly what
he means intern candace hooper breaks
her spine in a freak gymnastics accident
tech expert isaac palmer is taken out by
a variety of accidents during his
massage therapy and board member olivia
castle falls out of a building after
having her vision impaired during a
botched lasik surgery
next on death's list is factory
supervisor nathan sears but he's able to
avoid death's attempt and an employee
named roy carson takes the fall instead
according to william bloodward's theory
this may have changed nathan's position
by adding roy's remaining lifespan to
his own
you shorted death so you let death have
somebody else in your place
and then you take their spot in the
realm of the living all the days and
years that they've yet to live
and they take your place in death we
never find out if bloodworth is telling
the truth here though because as it
turns out roy only had a couple of days
left to live anyway
turns out roy had a large blood vessel
in his brain so big
he's about to burst and bloodworth is
also pretty adamant that you can't
escape
death so it seems quite possible that
this letting death have someone else in
your place business
is just an unproven theory that he's
testing otherwise you'd probably have a
bunch of immortal serial killers running
around
in the world of final destination this
is new york not haddenfield
it doesn't take long for the boss dennis
latman to be done in by a flying wrench
sales manager peter friedkin decides to
take out molly hoping to gain her years
but ends up settling for an fbi agent
named block instead shortly before sam
finishes him off with a
what is this thing called we'll just
call it a meat skewer on may 13
2000 sam and molly decided to start a
new life together in paris but before
their flight takes off a 17 year old
student named alex browning has a vision
he sees the plane malfunction and
explode causing him to freak out and
demand to be removed from the aircraft
six others from his french class are
also removed in the commotion alex's
foresight comes true and sam and molly
perish in the crash
a piece of the aircraft flies back
towards the city and crushes nathan and
several others completing death's list
from the north bay bridge collapse
but because six of the mount abraham
high school students and one teacher got
off the plane that they should have died
on
death must start a new list to clean up
these survivors at this point you
probably have a lot of questions
the previous disasters that i've talked
about have been relatively
self-contained
so if sam had never had a vision and the
presage employees had died on the bridge
collapse would flight 180
still have needed to crash or did death
take sam's vision into account
was the plan all along for him to
survive the bridge collapse that he
could die on flight 180. the way that i
see it once your time is up
your time is up and when that time comes
you may be able to put it off a little
bit but you can't really change history
you can't alter the bigger picture i'll
be able to fully explain what i mean by
the end of the video but for now
think of it like this if sam had never
had his vision the presage employees
would have died on the bridge but flight
180 was always destined to crash whether
their seats were filled
or not because sam and molly did survive
death altered its schemes just slightly
to put them on flight 180 which was
going to crash anyway
from here it just gets more and more
complicated because death's new plans
for the mount abraham students create a
butterfly effect
resulting in new survivors to be added
to death's growing list as well as other
disasters in different parts of the
world
[Music]
one of the coolest things about hunter
killer's blair witch game is that you
receive these boxes of evidence and
solve the mystery entirely from home but
you still have that sense of exploration
they do such a good job of building this
world that you end up becoming totally
immersed in these locations and attached
to the characters that you're trying to
help
if you love the slow burn pit in your
stomach type of horn this is the
alternate reality game for you
the story unfolds a little bit more with
each box making it a satisfying
adventure to take on with a partner but
an equally rewarding endeavor to solve
on your own
just don't come crying to me if the
blare wish ends up in your nightmares
actually on second thought i do want to
know if that happens there's even an
optional spoiler free online community
where you can collaborate with other
detectives to try to solve difficult
puzzles or share your own theories about
the characters in the story
this is your chance go to
huntakiller.com cz's world and use code
cz's world for 20
off that first box again code cz's world
20
discount what else could you really ask
for
[Music]
alex browning's best friend todd wagner
is first up on death's new list but
before death reaches him it's likely
that he did something to extend the life
of a man named evan lewis but we don't
really know exactly what
all we know is that evan was added to a
new list that death would deal with
later
in june of 2000 todd slips on some
leaked toilet water in his bathroom
ultimately causing him to accidentally
strangle himself on this clothesline
this is the point where i'd say that we
have proof that death is a force of
nature but also a character a grim
reaper trying to outsmart its victims
because after killing todd it cleans up
after itself by receding the toilet
water to make todd's death look like a
suicide
this was likely to throw off william
bloodworth who is now giving advice to
some of the accident survivors
death didn't want bloodworth meddling
with its plans it doesn't work though
bloodworth is still able to determine
the real cause of todd's death this
tells me that death is powerful but not
perfect and bloodworth's teachings to
flight 180 survivor clear rivers would
continue to be a problem for death going
forward
the next flight 180 survivor the death
reaches is terry chaney who was hit by a
bus but this also causes a woman named
kat jennings who was on that bus not to
reach the hotel that she was supposed to
die at so now she is added to that
second list behind evan lewis that goes
after the teacher that got off flight
180 valerie lewton by blowing up her
computer monitor
setting her home on fire and finally
letting her drop a kitchen knife into
her own body later that night alex saves
his classmate carter horton from being
hit by a train so death skips carter and
moves on to the next in line
billy hitchcock who is killed by a piece
of scrap metal that shoots out from
under the train
a police officer named thomas burke is
dispatched to investigate billy's death
causing him to not be there for a
shootout
that kills his partner since burke was
also supposed to die in the shootout he
is added to death's second list
the next day a teacher named eugene dix
is called in to substitute for miss
luton's class
causing him to be absent during an
attack that took place at the school
that he would have otherwise been
teaching at so he too
is added to death's second list it seems
like death is just letting the second
list grow
until after it's taken care of the first
list at some points nora and tim
carpenter are also added to the second
list
probably as a ripple effect of something
that alex browning did something he
would not have been able to do if he had
died on flight 180. the next victim is
clear rivers but alex manages to save
her so the target moves to him
six months go by before death makes
another attempt with clear's warning and
carter's quick action alex's life is
saved death cycles back through the list
so it's once again carter's turn
he isn't so lucky and he's struck by a
fallen restaurant sign
the commotion causes rory peters who is
nearby to miss his show at a local
theater which would later collapse and
he would also be added to the second
list
death makes dozens of attempts going
back and forth between clear and alex
before finally alex is knocked out of
the picture by a falling brick
clear goes into hiding in a padded room
where death is unable to reach her this
is another reason that i think death is
more of a character making conscious
decisions because if it were simply a
set of rules it wouldn't move on to that
second list until
clear was taken care of but with clear
locked away in isolation it didn't
really matter if death focused on other
things because she was unlikely to save
any of the others while she was in there
and if she did come out death would have
an opportunity to finish her but before
that happens is when i believe the
events of final destination spring break
take place we know this happens around
march because that's when spring breaks
tend to happen i think it's in the year
2001 because it seems to be after flight
180. there's a point where a character
sees that her flight is also 180 and her
eyes go wide but it can't be too far
into the 21st century they still have
standard definition tvs in the hotels
carly hagan and her friends are
vacationing at the hotel grand sulkin in
cancun mexico before arriving she has a
premonition of her hotel exploding when
she sees the signs from her dream
starting to come true she urges her
friends to go outside with her
because it's her birthday wish they do
just in time to see the explosion that
would have killed them
throughout the rest of the vacation
death comes for each of them chris is
chopped up by a boat propeller his
girlfriend katie breaks a thermometer on
herself and then trips and falls on some
sharp skeleton bones gino crashes
through a glass bottom boat while scuba
diving drina tries to leave cancun but
falls off the jet bridge after it's
struck by a runaway forklift jeremy
falls down during this and also dies
they're unable to leave the country with
an incoming hurricane
amanda drowns when the automatic pool
cover turns on while she's swimming
underwater matt's abs are not strong
enough to stand up to fireworks jake is
chopped up by a rescue helicopter brian
tries to hide from the hurricane in a
coffin but he never manages to make it
out and carly
well i'm not sure what exactly happens
to her she sees this creepy shaman in
the mirror and then
she just kind of disappears i don't know
dust in the wind i guess
after soaking up the sun in cancun death
returns to new york
still needing to take care of that
second list and see if anything can be
done about the hermit's clear rivers but
before doing that there are a couple
more disasters with unintended survivors
one involved a 38 year old
doris fenwick who is saved from drowning
her fate after that is unknown but we
can assume that death comes for her
the other is a larger incident that
becomes known as the infamous lakeview
fire we don't know if it was a
premonition that caused some of the
victims
to survive this time but given the track
record of the series it probably was
all of the survivors passed away in what
is described as an eerie string of
deaths but one of the last survivors was
a teenager named brian gibbons however
before taking out brian death decides
that now is a good time to try to
reclaim the lives of evan
tim nora cat rory eugene clear and
thomas
clear is still in the padded room though
so she's off the board for now so
death's new plan is to take out all the
others in a massive highway pileup i'll
also note that the order that they were
going to die in in the pileup doesn't
match up with the order in which they
were interfered with by the would-be
flight 180 victims because that order
isn't necessarily the order that they
would have died
if that explanation sounds confusing
think about it like this burke could
have gotten shot in that shootout but
not died from his injuries for another
couple
days we don't know because we don't see
any of that what i'm trying to say is
don't worry too much about the order
here
death's designs are thwarted once again
by william bloodworth who seems to
somehow make contact with a young woman
named kimberly corman
just before her very own flight 180
style premonition
[Music]
kimberly's vision not only saves those
who are on that second death list but
also herself leading her to basically be
added to that list
also death starts working backwards at
this point so the last one that should
have died in the route 23 pileup
kimberly is now the first target
why does death decide to go in reverse
here well this is twice that this set of
victims has gotten away so it might be
to try to catch them off guard
flight 180 has become kind of a
mainstream story at this point and maybe
death is worried that its victims are
figuring out its mo
death comes for kimberly immediately in
the form of a barreling truck but
officer burke pulls her out of the way
so her spot is skipped for now
evan is crushed by a ladder tim is
crushed by a glass pane and nora is
decapitated by an elevator eugene tries
to just give up and take himself out but
he's physically unable to do so because
it isn't his turn as explained by clear
who is now helping the new victims
i'm not really a fan of this rule but it
doesn't matter this is how it is
you literally cannot die until death has
decided that it's your turn
and it's cat's turn her airbag goes off
sending her head into a sharp pipe
rory actually encounters the lakeview
fire survivor brian gibbons and saves
him from being hit by a news van thus
extending his life a little bit longer
then we see the importance of death
taking them out in the correct order
again because it actually knocks down a
tree branch in order to move burke out
of the way
so he isn't hit by the barbed wire fence
that slices through rory
next up is eugene who has taken out an
explosion that also incinerates clear
now you might ask why clear was able to
die right here if it isn't her turn
i think it's because she's technically
still on the flight 180 list not the
route 23 list so on that list it's been
her turn the entire time
she's the last one with the last ditch
plan kimberly decides to drive into a
lake hoping that because she's next to
the hospital she would be treated
quickly and someone would be able to
revive her
this would theoretically invalidate
death's list according to what she was
told by bloodwork
and her and burke would be saved this is
the second theory proposed by bloodworth
this one actually has a little bit more
going for it because now we've seen
patty fuller's grandmother
patty fuller herself luis king and now
kimberly corman all survive using this
tactic
it's possible that they all died shortly
after but none of them are confirmed
dead
in fact kimberly and burke reunite with
the gibbons family for a barbecue at the
end of that summer in 2001 and the grill
explodes on brian
thus wrapping up the list of victims
from the lakeview fire it would be a
couple more years until death would have
to start another list i mean obviously
this kind of stuff is probably always
happening
off-screen but the next final
destination story would be final
destination death of the senses taking
place in 2003 a few years after flight
180.
jack curtis was the driver of the bus
that ran over terry cheney in 2000
you know the one that cat was also on he
would lose his job because of this and
become homeless and it is because he is
homeless that he's in the right place at
the right time to save a police officer
named amy tom from a serial killer that
means all the victims that the serial
killer would have gotten are now saved
so death has to take out each one of
them
the serial killer is referred to as john
doe and yes he's very similar to the
john doe from cesevinen but
instead of basing his crimes on the
seven deadly sins he planned to base
them on the five senses for sights he
was to take out a beautiful reporter
named chelsea cox death gets her with an
icicle on the air
well do it live for smell the target was
the man in charge of municipal trash
collection dawson donahue his car
explodes
taste was going to be food critic
dominique swann death blows up her wine
bottle and she's choked by a glass shark
touch would have been katie aston a talk
show host and televangelist who was
electrocuted
and for sound the victim would have been
joshua cornell iii a rapper producer
whose head is cut off when his platinum
record is launched through the air
during an equipment malfunction
of course there is one more and that is
the officer that jack saved amy tom
she is impaled by her own art piece and
then jack also dies even though he
wasn't technically on the list because
officer tom's partner thought that he
was the killer
oopsie on may 13th 2005 the five-year
anniversary of flight 180 and the
four-year anniversary of the route 23
pileup there are two more psychic
visions i would definitely understand if
this is becoming one of death's least
favorite days of the year the first is
in miami during final destination looks
could kill a woman named stephanie
pulaski
also known as sherry is part of a
modeling group called cellar where each
model is named after a different type of
wine during a party on a yacht called
the coral clipper sherry has a vision of
a fatal crash and she convinces her
boyfriend and some of the other models
to exit the boat before it departs when
the crash occurs for real a flying piece
of debris strikes sherry in the face
sending her into a coma
while she is being hospitalized a
similar disaster would occur further up
the atlantic coast
during a special grad night at mckinley
[Music]
park
that night in mckinley pennsylvania a
yearbook photographer named wendy
christensen has a horrific vision about
an accident on a roller coaster called
devil's flight
she causes a scene and several other
high school students get off the ride
before it crashes but wendy loses her
boyfriend
and her best friend because their car's
restraints were not released wendy sees
the ominous signs of death in her
photographs from that night and tries to
figure out their meaning so that she can
warn each of the others before they are
crossed off of death's newest checklist
popular girls ashley freund and ashlyn
halperin both become victims of a
tanning bed incident pervert's frankie
cheeks becomes a motorhead and not in
the heavy metal kind of way and football
star lewis romero is all bronze in no
brain
literally because his head is crushed by
a pair of giant weights wendy and her
friend kevin fisher are able to prevent
the death of ian mckinley so the next
target is his girlfriend aaron who is
spiked by a nail gun wendy's sister
julie was also on the ride and with the
help of kevin wendy's able to rescue her
but her friend perry is not so lucky and
gets impilled by a flagpole wendy and
kevin are both able to dodge death so it
comes back around to ian who is crushed
by a falling sign
so wendy kevin and julie are safe for
now
in august 2005 sherry is released from
the hospital stay that began with the
yacht crash
but she's forced to wear a mask to cover
her now disfigured phase and she thinks
that her life is over but like eugene
she's unable to end it herself she then
receives a phone call from death or at
the very least
someone posing as death who offers to
make her a special deal
we've never seen death be compromising
or try to make a deal with any of the
victims in the series so i think it
stands to reason that this caller is an
imposter they meet at a cafe where he
appears as an elderly black man
he asks her to help get rid of the
survivors that should have drowned that
day
in exchange for that he would restore
her face not only has death not taken a
human form before but it's never really
needed help killing anyone a fellow
model named chablis is eaten away by
spilled chemicals
shiraz's scalp is torn off and her head
is twisted around on a music video set
chardonnay hits her head and drowns in a
hot tub
rose's organs are vacuumed in a botched
liposuction surgery sherry's boyfriend
brutes is run over by a subway train
after falling into a manhole and a
photographer named gunter was crushed
after being pinned by the loading
platform of a delivery truck for each of
these deaths sherry has either played a
hand or watched idly as they happen
but she can't bring herself to kill her
best friend cabernet and because of this
she's broken the deal cabernet is also
pregnant and the delivery of her child
may be what saves her
remember the clue
only new life can defeat death but the
introduction of life that was not meant
to be
that could invalidate the list force
death
to start a new we've only seen the new
life can defeat death cheat used
successfully for people who were revived
but back in final destination 2
kimberly's original understanding of
this clue was that if someone who was
supposed to have died creates new life
by giving birth they could essentially
be off the hook
anyways after publicly screaming about
her deal with death sherry is admitted
to a psych ward in november wendy and
kevin are now in college and
julie meets both of them by chance on a
subway when wendy has another vision
this time she sees their train crashing
but unlike the roller coaster they
aren't able to get off we don't see what
happens after this but there is a
possibility that some of them survived
since every other vision in the series
has resulted in at least one person
being saved so it stands to reason that
these visions are always a clue about
how to avoid the hand of death
during the six months that follow sherry
gets better and even goes through a
facial reconstruction program
on may 13 2006 sherry is crossing a
street to meet up with cabernet when she
receives a phone call the caller id
simply says
death and cherry is struck down by a bus
as you can probably tell death seems to
be a gear head of some kind and he loves
vehicular accidents
just freaking adores them so in 2009 the
most vehicle-oriented disaster of them
all would occur the megatech 300 would
be held at mckinley speedway where
a guy i mean we don't really know what
he does named nico bannon would
experience his own flight 180 phenomena
he envisions a huge pileup where race
cars crash and tumble into the stands
taking out many fans so he pulls his
friends away from the action and in
doing so he inadvertently starts a fight
and is chased out of the stadium by
several people
their lives are saved when his vision
comes true but death gets to work
quickly a woman named nadia is
obliterated by a flying tire carter
daniels is dragged down the street and
lit on fire by
his leaking truck samantha is shot in
the eye when a lawnmower ejects a rock
and andy is diced by a fence
nearby there's kind of a side disaster
that happens when an out of control
truck crashes into a coffee shop and
runs over three mckinley high school
students
nick's friend janet is able to avoid
death's first attack at the car wash but
their friend hunt
is not so lucky as he's drowned and
sucked into a pool drain a man named
jonathan groves is crushed by a bathtub
that falls through from a floor above at
the hospital just like renoka from final
destination end of the line and a
security guard named george is hit by an
ambulance
just like seemingly half of the
population in this franchise being
killed by vehicles the remaining three
are nick his girlfriend lori and their
friend
janet nick has a new vision which leads
him to save the girls from an exploding
movie theater so death goes back to one
of its most reliable methods and hits
them with a truck
at the time of making this video this is
the last major death to occur
so by going through literally everything
all 1458 confirmed kills and that's not
including carly we've learned a lot
about the rules and tendencies of death
but like the actual concept of death in
real life there are still some things
that we'll never understand
however in looking at the bigger picture
we can get a better idea of how this all
works here's what i've gathered death is
unstoppable
the only way you may be able to avoid it
is with the introduction of new life
that was never meant to be but since we
never see any of the characters who
tried this later down the line we can't
say with 100 certainty that this works
so you can't avoid it but you can put it
off but if you do cheat death
don't expect it to last long the only
one who survived for an extended period
was clear and she did so by locking
herself away and not really interacting
with anyone thus not doing anything to
change the course of history in a major
way
the best comparison i can make to the
nature of the flight 180 phenomenon is
stephen king's 11 22 63. that story
involves a teacher named jake epping who
goes back in time to try to prevent the
assassination of john f kennedy but he
also tries to fix other things while
he's in the past which he believes will
make the world a better place in the
present but whenever he tries to change
history the universe fights back and
corrects whatever he does
and this makes it very difficult for him
to change a major historical event like
a presidential assassination so in
essence he's able to change little
details but things just get smoothed
over and eventually go unnoticed he
can't do much to change the destiny of
the universe and i think this is
basically how it goes in final
destination
if you have a vision about the future
you may be able to save yourself for the
time being but before long
death will correct your actions and you
will be the one to pay the price for it
click the video on the left to see my
analysis of other final destination
characters and if you love horror
remember to subscribe to cz's world for
new horrors every week ring the death
bell for notifications and i'll
see you in the next one assuming we both
survive
if you want to beat death use a face
mask and social distancing
[Music]